[Music]
good evening members
um to the reconvene meeting of the 8th
of September uh gender item one
Chairman's notices
um my name is councilor Boyce and I am
chairman of the modern District Council
Members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contribution as clear and
concise as possible thank you members
agenda item two apologies for absence Mr
Jennings
counselor councilor Helm you mean
Helm yeah
thank you Mr Jennings
um agenda item three
sorry councilor siddle oh yeah I'd like
to send apologies for Council of maze
because she's uh away for a personal
reason yeah uh thank you councilor Phil
um a general item three minutes of the
sixth of July contained on pages nine uh
to twenty to confirm the minutes of the
council meeting held on the 6th of July
2022 for accuracy only
do you accept these minutes by
acclimation
agreed thank you
uh agenda item for the minutes of the
25th of August 2022
to consider the minister of the
extraordinary council meeting held on
the 25th of August 2022
uh contained on pages 21 to 26 again do
you agree with them by Ascent
thank you members
agenda item five Declaration of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regards of paragraph nine and appendix B
are the code of conduct for members
members are also reminded that they are
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting is there any such declarations
councilor Durham
uh chairman and
you know
continue
yeah anyway anyway
this gives me this gives me great weight
so the point that I'm about to make as a
point of order eight
Open brackets three close brackets
um so I'm sure Mr Jennings will be aware
of this and I'm sure it's something that
in the past we've always abided by and
this chairman is the standing order
standing to address Council
I appreciate that this was a special
joke tell me and this case was acting
properly like the pandemic but generally
for the benefit Amendment says and it
has never been buried it will cause a
member when sleeping should stand and
address the chair
he said channel can you tell
and all of the people that mask
why this wall is not feeling better it's
the plot away I can say that hello the
chairman nodding in agreement can you
tell me why we don't do this anymore
councilor fluka you may have noticed
that I stood to address
um the council rather than address it
from the seat and it is my intention
that you should stand
um it may well give difficulties with uh
with trying to read the laptops at the
same time and now we've got the extra
problem of no microphones
uh and I don't know how this will affect
our live streaming
thank you chairman um I have an other
registerable interest as a member of
Essex County Council thank you and your
microphone's working
thank you very much
anybody else
chairman just just I mean if you don't
stand what what happens to you then
um I'll I'll I'll take that on
advisement as Perry Mason used to say
um can I have any other interests
I'll answer in a minute councilor
bettinger
what was that right Council Fleming
thank you chairman I understand from Mr
quelch that
um we don't need to declare as members
of Essex County Council unless there's
something on the agenda is that correct
um I I always used to not declare an
interest on Essex County Council because
it was written down on my register of
interests but I do believe things have
changed now but if Mr quelch has told
you that he gives good advice
thank you
counselor stamp
Stan please
counter counselor though that's the
information I have and I am not
declaring anything thank you very much
we can now go to
um agenda item six a public question
Pages 27 to 28 to receive questions from
members of the public which prior
notification in writing has been
received and I believe we have such a a
question that's been given and the
answer has been given and I believe
published now I think Mr Jennings the
the
um the answer of the question is not
present is that correct
you wouldn't know I suppose
yeah right thank you so can we take that
question as as asked and answered if it
has been published
thank you
um I should have said
um earlier that we've got a a lot on the
agenda tonight but my intention at the
moment is to try and complete it by 9
30.
uh now councilor passenger
um what happens if you don't stand up
well nothing except that as councilor
Fluker has pointed out it is in our
Constitution and as I am supposed to be
the defender of our Constitution which
is what councilor Fluker keeps trying to
point out to me that I am not defending
the Constitution
um however I think um uh the answer is
nothing will happen uh to anybody that
doesn't stand up except that they are I
don't even know whether that would
constitute a breach of the uh
uh members
um interests but there you go code of
conduct sorry thank you councilor Donald
um is that satisfactory answer for you
yeah it certainly is Mr chairman but I
was just wondering should there be
somebody who was disabled or something
would they then need to require would
they then need to require special
dispensation or would they be subject to
some sort of ridicule because they
didn't stand up no uh uh councilor
passenger uh what would happen if
anybody was disabled or if anybody was
feeling unwell and didn't feel able to
stand there would that would be no
problem and never has been a problem
right
um
we now go on to Chairman's announcements
um I I have
um we know the recent events uh and I've
had the privilege of taking part in part
of our National Heritage and and
pageantry which I feel very privileged
and that I would also like to commend
the CLT and all those officers that were
involved in the planning and the
implementation of what we now know was
London Bridge which was the death of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II
uh I would like to
commend them for the extraordinary work
they did and in particular those
officers that were present last weekend
thank you
[Applause]
um
to consider recommendation a gender item
eight minute book consider the
recommendations the first one is
performance governance and audit
committee agenda item eight equality
diversity councilor stamp please I think
this is in your body weight
members chairman I'd like to propose the
recommendation following the
requirements Governors and audit
committee based taking place on the 21st
of July 2022 chairman and the minutes
have not been approved so these are only
recommendations have not been approved
because PG a hasn't met since that
meeting but Council stamp this is a
recommendation that's coming from the
PGA and we will be approving this
recommendation or not yes without
explaining why it's coming chairman okay
how do you say that I thought you would
interrupt me it should be fair when I
actually took advice on what I should
say lead into this oh anyway I apologize
for that
it's only when I stand
the quality diversity and inclusion
action update annual review the
recommendation that the council's
constitution Constitution be updated to
reflect gender-neutral terms rather than
him stroke chairman from the options
they're set out in section 3.5 of the
report and member sanitations are
removed as
standard practice 3.5 German the
council's Constitution and current
practices use the term chairman and him
however the association of democratic
offices confirmed his best practice to
move away from gender-specific titles
and this would also be in keeping with
the Epi policy many councils have
already adopted this working practice
this report recommends removing the word
chairman and replacing with chair or
chairperson and also ensuring that
assuming the use of his per she he or
better still non-binary language there
then there as appropriate they accepted
that an individual May refer to
themselves or want to be addressed as
chairman or chairman or for the term if
they so wished me so I presented the
recommendations to cancer is that second
lid
all right thank you
um members agree
uh well
um yeah you can you can you can stand
and give your reasons if you wish yeah
yeah
all right okay
um I also vote against the chairman and
I'm standing councilor Darren
well chairman I I'm sorry but I firmly
believe that it should be the option of
the chairman to decide what they wish to
be called
um last time I looked um chairs had four
legs or sometimes three legs rather than
two
so my personal preference when I chair a
meeting would be called chairman and I
will intend to make that point when I
chair a meeting I think I think the
recommendation actually uh recognizes
um that I I myself have uh of God of you
that I think it's I've never intended to
say this is contrary to the Local
Government Act 1972 because that refers
to Chairman uh and
um I would wish to be called uh chairman
but I'm very often called chair but as
long as the conduct of the council and
businesses is done I'm quite happy
Council councilor Channel
[Music]
uh thank you chairman
um I think um I would say this I I
consider um always been a great
supporter of equality diversity and
inclusivity for various reasons which I
don't wish to expand on here but what I
would say is Chairman just to get
clarification I understand the
chairperson can establish what they may
wish to be called during that meeting
when they do their introductions can I
just then check regarding salutations
and I believe this might be the same
case if I so wish to call myself
counselor Mrs PA China because a fact of
life is I am married and have been for a
very long time and actually I'm quite
proud of that being called Mrs and
therefore I might like to
refrain and or rather rather keep that I
should say
salutation in terms of myself and in
fact officers do tend to call me that
um it's up to the individual office but
lots and call me counselor Mrs channel
so can I just check that equally that
may be able to apply so so that on my
name plate here I could have counselor
Penny Turner Mrs Penny Channer advice I
wish just kind of check that fact that
it is not saying we can't Define what we
might like to be called it's just
talking about the Constitution being
altered and those that go along with
that fine but if those others want to be
called chairman or other such names or
misses or miss or Mrs that's also
acceptable chairman thank you councilor
uh stamp do you want to respond to that
or do you want to listen to the whole
debate before you respond right
um councilor dewick oh yeah okay
um I think this is just another example
of
an audience
being accepted
long long time
proper for
I do not have
so share is a completely inappropriate
thing in my view so the last thing I
want to see is that this Council decides
we all can those
um chairs of a meeting are going to be
called jail referred to his channel I
personally find it distasteful
as I find much of the woke nonsense that
we are ending up
most of us nearly all of us I would hope
I would hope all of us know how to
behave all of us know how to treat
people properly and that is what we
should do we don't need all these
monsters put down in regulations for
who have decided that everything is
changing just for the sake of changing
it I just might even take your mind as I
said earlier I want my vote before the
beginning Bell
thank you
um Mr chairman members might not Mr
councilor during my very surprised to
hear me vehemently agreeing with him on
this issue now if you'd ask me this
question a year ago I would have
probably had well I would have had
completely the opposite view however
and cloak
women are finding ourselves being erased
in that reach at the moment currently I
referred to as birthing person
so remember I think this is a slippery
slope and I think we should resist
uh thank you chairman obviously I am the
member representative on the EDI working
group
what this recommendation States
is that our constitution is updated to
perhaps what it should have been done
about 20 or 30 years ago uh Constitution
should be gender neutral
so it should be there should be no
reference to he it should be they or
them when it comes to a committee
meeting
the whole point of EDI is that we are
referred to in the noun or the the way
that we want to be described this
recommendation does not stop that if
someone wants to be a chairman if
someone wants to be a chairperson
someone should be a chairman woman he
wants to be a Madam chairwoman it
doesn't stop any of that we can still be
called whatever we want to be called but
it's about the written Constitution
which is what we need to update
it should not be in a written
Constitution that refers to a male
gender that is out of date
and that's the crucial thing
because it is excluding anybody who
isn't male
thank you councilor Stevens
thank you chair um I was going to say
some of that so thank you
it is excluding people
um but particularly I just think anybody
that's worried that anyone is going to
mistake them for a piece of furniture
really perhaps need to think again on
that
language moves on and it a word that was
appropriate 300 years ago just might not
be now and that's just normal language
evolves and we shouldn't be frightened
of that thank you but the Local
Government Act
um hasn't changed it
in the last 50 years since it's 1972
Local Government Act councilor Thompson
thank you chairman
um I absolutely Echo councilor Bell's
sentiments I feel that I agree with her
very strongly her current views even if
they used to be different I'm certainly
with her now I don't disagree with
councilor siddle but I I do have a
problem with the English language in
that they in there in very few
circumstances is meant to refer to one
person I just don't want to see it turn
into a muddle that he isn't so bad but
the him her the they there all over the
places I think gonna make a bit of a
mess of it and I don't don't feel
excluded by you know not being included
specifically as a Miss Mrs musk's
whatever else we can be these days
um it's not as I'm concerned the
Chairman's job not a person and I'm a
chairman thank you very much
any other member
um
obviously
um uh you can sum up um uh councilor
stamp if you so wish and then we'll take
a vote because it there is a councilor
Lagan
share it with you
I might relocate to a microphone it
actually works because we're excluding
people on the live streaming I I'm aware
of that and I'm noting that some mics
are working and some aren't and the
advice I've had is they're all on the
same line so they should be working
okay please please find yourself another
mic if you so wish
I think
this is 20 22 now
it's not 1950. I think we inheritism in
history some things should be maintained
retained greatly which is our very
supportive and maintaining our own
history Heritage and I think people are
very different now to what they were in
20 30 40 to 50 years ago
it counts as simple I think it's time to
bring things up to date with a historic
prostitution that is for a district
council this is a real good you know Mr
Sheen shot puppets backside to sort of
hang out so I think we need to result
today
in the way that people can be who they
want as Council City says you can be
what you want this
so we're not excluded I mean we're just
saying camera right
well if if whatever I maybe wish to be
to referred as that doesn't put an
imposition upon anybody else actually
meeting my wishes I wish to be called a
chairman you always have called me chair
uh I've got no problem with that
councilor fluka
tonight
so it might be an idea but when the
chairs introduce themselves
they just clarify what they want to be
called and if it's a chairman Council
and a lovely benefits
councilor stem
as long as it doesn't take any choice
away
um I myself would prefer to be called
mother chair or chair General and I
don't really mind but if somebody has a
strong
um lean in which way they want to be
called and what they want to be called I
think it's vital that discounts have
actually adopted
um so you know I've got the
recommendation Mr chairman you've got to
take the vote right those in favor of
the recommendation from PGA please show
um who's counting
well
um those against
nine
um that's uh um passed then uh the
Constitution will change uh I had this
debate with or discussion uh with Mr
quelch before and he described it
um as the the use of chairman in the
local government act as an office so
therefore I'm now a chair in that office
um
uh Item B uh overview and scrutiny
committee
um
uh that would be Council Fleming
no those are sorry uh councilor Spencer
Lee
um
I bring you the following recommendation
from our meeting on the 28th of July
this year
recommended that the counter causes the
current review methodology of the ldp
all members be invited to an
extraordinary meeting of the council to
consider options with regard to The
Limited only news and this is a partial
review of the ldp as required rather
than a full change to the council's
current strategy so I present this
recommendations thanks thank you um we
actually have actually held this
extraordinary meeting of the council but
we needed to go through the process
that's a recommendation that's come
forward but we've actually
um already held it
um uh then
councilor Lagan sorry
this recommendation
because it talks about um
partial review so it hasn't had to be
done in this meeting we've had an extra
one for a previous functional platform
so this recommendation from this
community
uh I'm gonna need to take advice on this
because
um I understood that that extraordinary
meeting was to consider this
recommendation councilor spenceley
thank you chairman um my understanding
of that was that we we looked at the
five-year housing land Supply and the
working group being set up specifically
but that didn't uh it's been made very
clear to us that the five-year housing
land Supply is actually a separate issue
so that I'm not sure how that completely
addressed his recommendation thank you
um Miss Holmes
can you advise me please
okay
it was not specifically that
recommendations
uh Mr Dodson has has an answer uh Mr
Dodson is your night working
uh Mr Jennings
all I was going to say sure that it
helps that certainly this red foundation
will came out of the overview and
scrutiny committee's consideration of a
motion reference in relation to the
fiber land Supply whether it goes
further and Beyond what you feel the
council has already done for is perhaps
another issue but it's certainly arrives
from discussion on the five year
landscope uh thank you Mr Jennings
um councilor Edwards and then counselor
so thank you Jim I'm just trying to find
the minutes from the extraordinary
meeting it was to discuss the
methodology mythology of How It's
calculated not what's on this motion
okay
um councilor Swain councilor settle
um thank you
um chairman um two things
um the the
um whether the question is whether the
meeting that has taken place did fully
discuss the methodology of the ldp or
not but this motion this recommendation
has got two things in it one concerning
the methodology of that and also this
question of whether we
um should do a partial rather than a
full
um review of the ldp it seemed to be we
should take those two items separately
or two aspects separately
cancerous little and then the leader I
think uh yeah thank you chairman yeah
that's the point I was going to make the
the actual recommendation states that
there's a a party looks at whether we
need a partial review of the local plan
and not a full review of the local plan
um obviously things have moved on and
we've had that extraordinary general
meeting since that particular time so
it's it's whether it's this review thing
and the type of review in terms of our
local plan I I think that's the bit
that's perhaps different to what we've
done already
um leader
I think next um thank you chairman well
I I think you may have been going to Mr
Dodson my understanding was chairman um
because I did ask this question and my
understanding was that actually the the
uh motion that went and had to the
extraordinary meeting which of course I
I couldn't be at because I um
unfortunately was unwell
um was actually sufficient to cover this
that's my understanding and I believe
and I'll let I'd be having to uh put
words in Mr dodson's mouth but I thought
there had been discussions about this
with I thought councilor login if I'm
honest because I did see something
saying that I thought councilor Lagann
was to be putting the motion forward on
behalf of rovian scrutiny and that is my
understanding because I did check this
out so I would like some clarification
chairman
um because I wasn't involved in the
discussions it would be helpful and I
have subsequently asked that question
again thank you
um uh councilor Spencer I'll come to you
uh because it's your recommendation to
uh to at the end councilor Lagoon first
yeah yeah that Point's been made
okay
um
uh councilor spenceley
thank you chairman so um
my suggestion would be that could that
not be included within the terms of
reference of the working group that
we've set up
so that the terms of reference for the
working group is looking at the five
year back if if as Vice chairman of uh
overview and scrutiny that is what
you're suggesting then usually that is
what the council will accept
Council Spencer are you are you
proposing that
pretty much
Council fluka
find out what's going on um
because they had recognized how emotive
this is and I'll speak to validation
along the city but this is to do with
remember this being anxiety
I don't think
maybe let us want to shake again
sorry uh Mr Council floor could please
carry on
um
councilor spensely if I come to you that
will be you will be the last person
yes I agree it's what you know I can't
decide to do something different it is a
recommendation that over here is
always in there for it is the
recommendation that I present as it is
to the council thank you I'll set them
up
as well yeah oh uh we'll we'll take the
vote those in favor of this please
it's not going to be funny
um
Mr Jennings recorded recording vote has
been called forward you've got your
uh
um Mr Dodson have got it Mr Dodson will
do it
um those those in favor
say agree those against say
sorry
yeah
it was seconded yeah it was seconded
um we're just getting ready to take it
Council boys what are we voting on I'm
not really clued up on this sorry
you're voting on the recommendation
that's come from overview and scrutiny
committee
Mr Dodson would you read out
um the recommendation from overview and
scrutiny please
or the relevant part
thanks
it's recommended that the council pauses
the current review methodology of the
ldp all members be invited to an
extraordinary meeting of the council to
consider options with regard to the
methodology used and considers a partial
review of the ldp as required rather
than a full change to the council's
current strategy
okay have you got that so those in favor
say agree
yes I I
know councilor Lagan it's a recorded
vote
um those in favor say agree and those
who are against say against
are you clear
right Mr Dodson call the roll please
councilor passenger
great
counselor Miss Beale
councilor Bell
councilor Boyce against
sorry I meant to say abstain
I knew it began with an eye
it's time
councilor Mrs China
against
councilor duwick
councilor Durham
councilor Edward agreed
a councilor Mrs Fleming
agreed
councilor fluka
councilor head
agreed
councilor hebner
councilor Hull
councilor keys
abroad councilor Lagan
councilor Morgan
against
councilor Morley
councilor Nunn
agreed
councilor Shaughnessy
councilor siddle
agreed
councilor spencerley
councilor stamp
councilor Stevens agreed
councilor Mrs stilts agreed
councilor Swain agree and councilor Mrs
Thompson against chairman thank you
that's obviously Carrie but we'll get
the figures in a second
so it's not adding up
um uh it is it is actually breathed by a
large majority oh is there any absent oh
no that was called for wasn't it sorry
um 1542 again 15 4 15 4 2 again one
abstention
yeah
three again 15. 3 is 18. one is 19.
we're all the others
Mr Dodson
I think I think there's about 27 of us
here
yes right okay twenty two four three
twenty two four three against him 22 for
three against and one abstention that is
Carrie then thank you uh uh councilor
Spencer Lee could I
um chairman given given that the request
is within 10 days no it's not that's not
it's not really in 10 days oh okay
um
right agenda item nine uh minutes uh
meetings of the council which you have
all before you
uh is there any questions on any of
those
no uh now we go to gender item 10 notice
of motion
uh councilor uh Lagan
um
to move his motion
I would appreciate that we've got it in
front of us
yeah
it doesn't work Chris
it's important that people have more
than the district here hear the motion
so in essence remember members I bought
a motion requesting that local members
be involved in the decision-making
process in their local assets that
motion um failed which was probably the
decision that I was expecting because
there wasn't enough it was too broad so
myself and other members have gone back
and the motion that we've got and the
procedural rule forward just basically
we've had an awful lot of criticism
about decision-making processes on on
mold and Promenade so what I've asked in
this motion basic motion one is that the
motion to be recommended to PG a
committee for review and consideration
and any recommendations brought to full
Council and motion two which is the meat
and the potatoes of it where we've asked
for a Nuance involvement within a
decision-making process not to be the
decision makers but what it basically
says to to enable a more inclusive
process that the schema delegation be
updated to include active elected member
participation in decision making for
certain matters at Malden's much love
Promenade Park and historic key
so those are changes are on part A to
amend the scheme of Delegation as is
part three responsibility and function
section 44 parks and Open Spaces be
formal Recreation areas in any building
they're in the letters of stores kiosks
and other operations are there on
including the letters of such fun Fizz
surfaces and other short letters that
are letting to be responsibility and
functions under Section 44 parks and
Open Spaces formal Recreation areas
other operations there on including
letters of funfair circuses and other
short-term letters with the inclusion
inclusion of Ward members officers and
modern members work together to consider
proposals for the letting of kiosks and
stalls
okay so it's not trying to take over the
operations of the Promenade Park and the
key it's being involved
okay to represent the members the
members of public and Part B of this is
asset management section 56 DNE are
amended to negotiate the terms of new
leases including interim initial rent
both at Market rent and those cases
where existing tenants have a statutory
right to call for new leases on expiry
of the current term and to authorize
completion of such new leases with an
annual value of 15 000 in duration not
exceed in seven years
um really the the nuts of the motion is
that we're asking for minor changes to
have an involvement
um in in the previous uh responsible
officers was that it's too complicated
because it's too broad and the
negotiation takes a long time I fully
get that
um but I think that being involved
um in in matters is in crucial as part
of being a democratically elected
members who actually live in the in the
area that we're talking about and I've
got on my desk over there I left it from
a very disgruntled resident about
decisions that are being taken on a prom
I was on my holidays in Greece when I
received emails and complaints from
residents about things that happen on
the prom if we knew about them we had
the opportunity to contribute to those
decision-making processes I think we
were in a better position as individuals
more than Ward members to actually
explain the situations that we're
bringing on so members I ask you just to
support the motion previously
difficult to change the Constitution but
we've just done that on a previous
motion so previous debate so well
therefore I I leave it there thank you
uh councilor lag and you you're actually
your Motion One recommends that this
your motion to go to the PGA well as
you're aware I've made a ruling that it
should be heard tonight so it might be
necessary for you actually to withdraw
your motion uh uh one with the consent
of your your secondary if that's okay if
you're if you're happy with that oh
thank you chair anything to streamline
will be welcome I'll just if my second
is okay with that I'm fine uh right so
uh um Mr Jennings is that
um uh recorded properly
question yeah thank you
um uh that was seconded is that is that
uh councilor Stevens no no you're not
secondly
um was councilor lagan's motion seconded
yes all right councilman uh Nan thank
you uh right I've got councilor Stevens
and councilor stamp
thank you chair I just want to check
um a point of clarity here at the top
I'm gonna have to sit down because I
can't see it I do apologize at the top
of page five second paragraph reads with
the inclusion of Malden Ward members
officers and Malden members should that
say and quite clear what that's really
meant to me
Gem and I wondered if I could put an
amendment to the motion yes of course
you can
um
you want you want more you want more
members to determine Riverside Park
[Music]
that that that is
um that's a large implication amendment
I think
yeah it well yeah for the time being
that's what I'll rule
it's out
uh councilor Thompson and then the
leader
Igan won't be happy to hear this but I'm
afraid he's heard it before I mean I I
thought someone might raise the
Riverside Park and if counselor stamp
hadn't I would but the fact is all these
assets belong to the whole of the
district so if Malden members are being
consulted to be honest I want to be so
let's have an extraordinary Council
every single time we debate anything
under Parks because Everyone's entitled
to use them everyone owns them everyone
shares them and everyone travels from
all over the district and indeed Beyond
to use them so I'm afraid I can't
support this I think it's it's too much
in favor of very local members just
because they live near the park
represent people near the park thank you
uh leader and then Council fluka
um thank you chairman I know when the
original motion came up I did um
actually give my reservations then at a
meeting
um because of the concerns about Excel
to make me look as though there was some
executive powers going to Malden members
but I can see there's been some
moderation regarding what's coming
before us tonight but what I would say I
do agree with the comments made the prom
Park actually is of an asset of the
whole district and therefore all members
should be able to be included if you
know inclusivity to have views on that
I'm now hearing about the Riverside Park
and no disrespect to council Sam I've
actually got some assets in my ward and
what should really happen is I have
always been made aware of things ahead
of anything discussions councilor
Hellman I actually have been I met in
the past with officers about it and
recently something to do with an asset
in my board we were kept advised and
informed all the way along until what
was needed to be completed had been and
I think it counts it's what councilor
Stevens has also alluded to asking for
Malden District councils to be applied I
think what will happen is we're going to
see that everyone will be seeking to
have this regarding their respective
order like councilor Thompson referred
to and I do believe it will create
actually operational difficulties for
officers and we need operational
um you know activities to be able to run
efficiently and smoothly and I think
this will cause issues I can see where
councilor login's coming from I
thoroughly appreciate his views on this
but I'm afraid that I won't be able to
support it for the reasons I've given
and we've already heard what other
members want and what they was and I've
heard councilor Thompson say and I'm
afraid that will Ricochet throughout the
whole of this chamber I believe thank
you chairman
Council Fluker
yes
now Council fluka okay
um
okay
they should be consulted anyway so maybe
we're not maybe we're not executing this
wall
popular
um
issue
um I I think I think Council of cloaker
your your correct in the war members
being advised but whether that is custom
and practice uh or protocol I don't know
that it's actually written down but Mr
Dodson wants to clarify I think this
point
yes it's essentially uh stand up Mr
Dodson please
did stand up
they do
when
we never did anyway and now you'll see
the impracticalities of standing and
talking to a laptop yeah I wanted
actually to to read out a statement from
um Richard Holmes director of Service
delivery which actually agree with as as
well
um he said the scheme of Delegation has
been operated by officers for many years
without incident officers operate the
process in accordance with the scheme
which is designed to ensure operational
activity can proceed without delay
boundaries are understood as tested by
the recent overview and scrutiny review
of the new kiosk in prom Park
both the commercial manager and
operations manager have met with Ward
members to discuss operational issues on
a regular basis is accepted that through
covid this has been less frequent but
they were never designed to seek
approvals for individual projects
concessions Etc my honest belief is that
the scheme of Delegation is fit for
purpose the controlled sort through the
motion could be better met through the
prom Park management plan and Commercial
strategy which will set the boundaries
for operations with greater Clarity
leaving officers to manage the
day-to-day business and finally prom
Park is a district asset and projects
and activities in the area reflect this
the park has the ability to generate
Revenue to the council through providing
an income stream
officers strive to seek a balance which
may mean at times it may be at odds with
individual members views thank you thank
you
um councilor stamp you've already spoken
is there councilor Darren
well thank you and then Council thank
you chairman Not For the First Time
councilor for Luke as well as we've
stolen my thunder
um
chairman whether it's in the
Constitution or not it's certainly good
manners
for the relevant Ward members to be
informed of anything significant
happening that in in their Ward but I
would go on to say that the events that
take place in the Promenade Park and
indeed Riverside Park the part of the
commercial strategy of this Council and
they produce profits for the benefit of
the entire district and the residents of
that District so I don't really think
that it's
advisable that extra weight is given to
the to the the members in that
particular Ward but as I said I think
that it's absolutely essential
when there are events that the members
in that particular Ward are notified and
kept abreast of anything significant
that may prompt a future comment from
their residents thank you
um councilor Swain and then I think the
second of the motion which is to speak
councilor now thank you chairman yes
um some points on this um
firstly
um I'm glad Mr Johnson mentioned a
management plan for the park I hope
that's going to emerge fairly soon but I
think it's been about three or four
years in the gestational and I'm not
sure it's actually progressed much so we
would like to say that and referring to
councilors
um point about good manners to consult I
think it does we do need more than that
um I I have experienced that we get
um with officers that uh
um both these catch-up meetings that
we've had which haven't been quite as
frequent as um as desired
um and been
informed and had discussions to try and
uh influence say
um events in in Palm Park but I don't
claim to or want to have um it wouldn't
be right to have any sort of veto on
what happens in in gun Park which is of
course my ward
um
as far as so it's a question of this
what we mean by involvement
um I don't think involvement in the
decision making is is is workable but I
think we do need involvement in the
sense that we want to have good
information beforehand and the ability
to discuss it with officers
um of whatever is coming up
um so I think this is really asking too
much and I agree you know with the
burner members who um
see this as being rather a privileged
position for the plum Park and the hide
so um I I think that's just opening can
of worms and therefore I think this is
uh I mean I shall vote against it
um the councilman the second that wishes
to speak councilman you all had the
opportunity to sum up at the end
uh thank you very much chairman um when
councilor Lagann contacted me about this
motion I was more than happy to Second
it um whilst I agree with some of the
things that members have said about this
being a district asset it is
nevertheless a substantial uh uh and
major one and has gathered and generated
an awful lot of public interest and like
Council Lagan my post bag both emails
and paper post is very much around that
subject and I think the way I read this
motion was that simply the the members
the elected members on the ground who
surely will know most about the prom
park being the elected members for that
area are the ones that should be
involved in discussions about decisions
that are going to be made this is not to
undermine the scheme of Delegation this
is simply to forewarn and forearm
members who will receive these kind of
inquiry worries and at the moment
actually I feel a bit of a nelly when I
get phone calls from the general public
when I don't even know what's going on
with these concessions so it's surely
the Democratic process is to involve
those democratically elected members
where part of it was hired out for a
wedding
next to the area where there is some
great benches of remembrance we knew
nothing about it and it caused absolute
outrage and like councilman we were
unable to fend off any composer
inquirers because we won't talk for them
thank you
right
um
councilor Morgan councilor Edwards and
councilor Stevens I I don't think any of
you have spoken yet
councilman
yeah thank you chair I just want to say
in my day job as a
trip 20 years negotiating leases and
seeing the complete screw-ups the
professionals make negotiated I'm going
to be inputs or inputs from Members may
not necessarily be of any real help to
anybody
um
did I say Council Stevens next
and the cancer in Edwards thank you
chairman
um I'd like to
um mention the fact that heybridge also
has assets large assets in particular
Draper's Farm Sports Club of which I'm
appointed to an outside body to that
committee Hospital sports club and if
anything's been discussed regarding
Draper's Farm Sports Club I would like
to be involved not just as a war member
but I represent this Council on their
committee thank you thank you Council
Stevens
thank you chair I just want to come back
to what I asked earlier because it was
just a question it wasn't and I think
this is wrong it was a question I'll
lift my laptop up this time I hadn't
thought of that before
it says with the inclusion of Malden
Ward members and I'd take that to mean
Warden Ward members of Malden town
as opposed to Malden District but I'm
not certain officers and Malden members
and it's just a question I don't
understand that statement so please
could somebody explain it to me thank
you
[Music]
um
um I'm told
there as councilor Swain has pointed out
as far as the prom and the key are
concerned he is the only Ward member
um but I thought councilor lagam was
wishing to include all Malden Ward
members District Ward members which is
what sets five or seven or something
um councilor Swain
Easter's point of clarification
um
chairman
um I'm the ward member that covers
Promenade Park but
um High's key falls in northward of
which councilor Nan is is a member thank
you for that clarification that's a
perfectly correct interruption
that was a point of uh explanation
um counselor hurt
we haven't heard from you
not yet chairman no thank you
um I think that we've we've already
heard the answer from this and that is
through the report of Mr Holmes a man
who I think has the highest Integrity uh
he's saying that this is already fit for
purpose I think that this motion is
nothing but interference and I think
that the scheme of Delegation is already
in place and it's working I think it's
too specific from all the members as
councilor Edwards has quite rightly said
there are properties outside of Malden
and you could and if something happened
at uh
uh the area surrounding Morrisons you
know should I be should I be informed to
this I think we all have uh meetings
with the directors through our leaders
and leaders of the opposition and those
things can be brought up there but as Mr
Holmes has said uh it's fit for purpose
and and if it's good for Mr Holmes it's
good for me
thank you Council
um
councilor Durham has spoken before uh
and in fact I think most members have
have spoken
um now I think the Constitution Council
of Fluval correct me if I'm wrong uh the
Constitution the Constitution uh says
that the leader has the penultimate
speech and then the move of the motion
uh has the summing up uh leader did you
wish to uh say anything at this stage
well chairman uh nothing more really
than I think I said at the beginning I'm
you know having listened to the debate
now
um My Views are the same of those that
have been echoed in this chamber by some
members
I do feel I can see as I said I respect
where Council wagons coming from and
obviously councilor none who seconded
the emotion but I do feel it will cause
complications involving as counselor
herd has also highlighted the delegation
scheme that's working there has been
working I think I said when I spoke
initially it will cause operational
difficulties and I did say that's
happened with me in councilor Helm that
regarding our Ward where there's been
assets members should be actually spoken
with and Views but not necessarily in
the way that Council again seeking
because I can see it becoming an all
district matter where everyone will want
to be afforded the same privileges for
one of a better word if if this is
approved so chairman I'm afraid I I
won't be supporting it for those very
reasons I think those members have
spoken very well as Regarding why they
can't and Council Swain I take great
counsel from bearing in mind he does
actually represent the Promenade Park
thank you Jim Council Lagan would you
like to sum up before we take the vote
just a couple of things Castle Morgan
I'm not interested
contracts from very good commercial
manager seats
for the council at home if you want to
go into one of Mount Morrisons bring it
to the council and see if you can find
out about my results there get more
active involvement but I'll just leave
it to people to make decisions for you
other members this is what it's about
you were related to represent your areas
okay my motion in the past was too broad
you said bring it back make it Arrow
we've made it there and they will run
out of town
proportion this says okay it says with
the inclusion of all the members all the
board members officers and moment
members work together to consider
proposals it does not say we negotiate
it does not say we make decisions it's
in the united Constitution to be
involved at the source of it the
conversations is equally involved in a
conversation no good people but I'll
take a bit of public places
good idea
foreign
we don't even know Mr Holmes I also
Council early holders comes in great
step lamb was a brilliant I think it's
getting delegation is lazy
transformation that's where it stems
from was lazy and hasn't worked so when
you're trying to actually do what you're
supposed to do as an effective member
stand up to people in your area and I
think you should do that yeah rather
than I'd be able to know so it's
destined to fail I knew that I wrote it
but I couldn't put myself in the mirror
in 10 years time I'll do exactly the
same account if I'm trying to put
somebody else's support uh thank you
councilor lag and we'll we'll now take
the vote those in favor of councilor
lagann's motion please show
thank you
hello ten those against
uh 14 that motion is lost
thank you very much we'll now move on to
the second motion is it
sir
ens
yeah
that's really easy to access it
you can even have a chair or stand in
front of them that's nice great to see
the former chairman the other one case
have to get you did an excellent job
um chairman just give me a moment to uh
just rearrange my papers
um but chairman when I did while I do
that can I um remind everybody chairman
that we've just started the new Caroline
rain
um
and
on that note Gem and I wish everybody
peace health and prosperity for that
Reign God Save the King chairman
um
chairman I I've had literally tens of
emails about this two lots because we've
had sadly had to have another council
meeting
um
for the benefit of all members I mean
it's it's elected members elected
members who represent the community
and they are responsible for Place
shaping apart from anything else for
those of us that were here during the
2014-2029 local development plan process
um all of the members were involved
right the way through that process right
from the beginning
and we dealt with the subsequent
agreement of emergency emerging policies
and cancel the channel I remember in in
her capacity those days as the chairman
of of uh
planning and uh I can't let you forgive
me playing a licensing committee did an
enormous amount of work on this and and
during that time members considered
whether or not to allocate one large
site for growth or opt for several
smaller ones and likewise the principles
of garden suburbs which are actually
brought forward by by councilor Cheshire
he actually LED on this concept and it
was what we did they're also long and
protracted debates concerning pepper
potting the spreading on the houses
throughout the district and the
sustainability credentials of rules
Villages and this was all done before we
did anything else before we called for
sites before we did anything members
were directly involved in decision
making through a series of meetings a
council and as a result residents and
other interested parties could see for
themselves
the Democratic process the place shaping
taking place where we are at the moment
chairman is is we you know we have these
policy working groups then something
goes off to council and we never really
all come together we've never had the
opportunity the review of the local
development plans included a call for
science of which some have been
considered by officers as being
acceptable and the people that have
brought forward those sites have been
told that they are acceptable and I
return to that at the moment this has
resulted in residents and others
believing that the future development of
these sites is actually a face accompli
or a done deal
which is called much consternation and
stress and uncertainty for lots of
resonance
more notably when I speak to Residents
more noticeably I mean the ones in the
Crouch Valley defense group and those
that live in Hawthorne where potentially
1 000 or more properties could come
forward I mean if anybody is driven down
the lower Burnham Road you would be
absolutely amazed how may I can see
people nodding couldn't counselor said
welcome to Autumn
um you'd be absolutely amazed at how
many signs are down there and and and
some quite strong messages to Malden
District Council which I I take
exception to because it says modern
District Council do your job I don't
think we've I actually don't think we've
been given the opportunity so far to do
our job on this
so and I sort of uh
need to make it absolutely clear that in
my mind I don't believe that we've
agreed these policies of these emerging
sites it's accepted that the emerging
policies of cite allegations have been
discussed by working groups at the
council but previously these hugely
important decisions including the
associated overarching policies were
debated and agreed by members on an
ongoing basis
for clarity the terms of reference of
the working group are called agreed by
the extraordinary meeting of Council on
the 25th of August Deals Only with the
assessment of the five-year housing
Supply it doesn't deal with this
in summary chairman it's considered that
generally members have had little formal
input into decisions regarding the
allocations of sites and the
opportunities to consider other options
and there are other options
and new policies have not been the
subject of democratic input or scrutiny
by members I mean at a recent working
group meeting
um you know we would there were
suggestions of Estates of 2000 houses
providing all sorts of things this needs
to be discussed in full Council and it
needs to be discussed by all members not
by small working groups
um and going back just to give some a
little bit more weight about my concerns
about these sites that have been deemed
as suitable for development
so
two weeks ago we we had a plan in policy
meeting and it was said that the
assessments issued
by to developers by the policy team
where they've said that they're suitable
for development have been caveated
with the words subject to a
sustainability test well from the
developers I've spoken to and who've
contacted me
they don't recognize those words but of
course
when you look at some of these sites
they're very very large sites and as
they stand if you just look at them as
they are they are not sustainable
because most of them will be bringing
forward other
other bits of infrastructure to make
them sustainable so how you can say it's
suitable I don't know German and that is
what concerns me with this enormously
and then we've got this other issue and
I think we're going to be faced with
this issue I'll be quick chairman well
we've got over five minutes on being
very uh you're being more than generous
but we've also got this other issue
where we've got members of the policy
team saying that a site is acceptable so
if the applicant puts in a planning
application and it's refusing it goes to
appeal we then have a situation whereby
development management the DM team will
be defending the appeal on behalf of
this Council and the applicant will be
calling a hostile witness from policy to
me that makes no sense whatsoever so
champ my motion is is is quite
straightforward and and I think Mr
Dodson mentioned there's 10 working days
earlier and my notion is Chairman is
that we call an extraordinary meeting of
council and this meeting takes place in
not less than 10 working days there is
lots of information that's already gone
to the policy working groups so that can
all be presented to council and then
with that meeting is exclusively to
consider the emerging policies of the
review of the 2014-2019 2029 local
development plan and specifically the
allocations of sites including those in
all phones and indeed throughout the
district chairman that is my motion
um hopefully it will be seconded is that
seconded and I and I think well let's
have who is a second who was the
seconder on the paper
do you wish to speak now or or later
thank you
um before we uh move on I think I'd like
to
um have some officer input um into this
and uh call on I think Mr Winslow Who's
online somewhere
well
um
uh sorry uh Mrs Channel which is clear
and interest
um chairman I think all members in this
chamber might be aware that I do live in
Hawthorne however tonight is not
discussing a planning application and
actually allocations have not been made
that is my understanding on it and what
I can say is I may live in Hawthorne but
I will not be affected any more than the
great majority of residents that live in
Hawthorne or perhaps Beyond I have
spoken with the monitoring officer and
bearing about this is really about
timing and process rather than talking
about specific applications which is not
on this agenda it's a shame in a way
that it has got so specific and
mentioning various things about the
Crouch rally group having spoke with the
monitoring officer I can tell you that I
do not have an interest in this
particular motion and item has come
forward chairman thank you thank you for
that declaration uh Mr Winslow sorry Mr
chairman if I may uh is this it is
only only as much as I am the world
member for Hawthorn and I also live in
Hawthorne and I have seen all the signs
uh I have no interest in the um
the pressure group in Hawthorne but I do
live in Hawthorne so I will declare that
thank you for that uh uh I'll try again
Mr Winslow would you like to um uh give
the council uh information please
initiated following a decision of
Council on the 23rd of February 2021 to
consider and approve the Morton District
local development scheme 2021-2024
this approved a very accelerated
programmer preparing an ldp review
similar to what was envisaged by the
government's planning white paper which
sort of saw it being submitted to the
government in Spring 2023 being examined
by a planning inspector in summer 2023
and being adopted by the Autumn of the
Year this therefore set the pace of
preparation on the 18th of March 2021
Council in turn established a new
planning policy working group its
purpose was established as an Advisory
Group as a board strategy and resources
committee and the council in the legal
and sound development of planning policy
guidance set out in the local
development scheme
it would be a working group consisting
seven members of the council
the terms of reference of the working
group were agreed to firstly provide
cross-party member engagement and
discussion in the work being undertaken
to prepare the policy document set out
in the local development scheme secondly
to provide informal feedback and
discussion with officers on key draft
evidence documentation and policy
options to guide officers formulating
recommendations to strategy and
resources committee thirdly to provide
regular updates to the strategy and
resources committee on its work
informing the ldp review and any
supplementary planning Document
Preparation and finally to take an
active part in any planning policy
training and encourage other members
outside of the working group to attend
that training when offered to The Wider
membership of the council
has reported to strategy and resources
committee on the 14th of July 2022
during the
2021-2022 municipal year of your working
group had met 11 times over a 10-month
period since its formation and from
March 2022 the working boots meetings
were open to non-working group members
and all members have been able to attend
and contribute to the discussion and
debate since
procedurally the council consulted on a
local development plan review issues and
options document which contain questions
around the issues that could face the
review of existing planning policies and
Broad options for future building
districts
the issues and options document did not
contain any site-specific information it
was published for public and stakeholder
consultation between January and March
2022
evidence that had been prepared by this
consultation was also published
including the housing and economic land
availability assessment which included
land submitted in the forms of science
the rural facilities study and
assessment pattern reviewing which
should be noted the findings of these
published evidence studies are neither
current nor emerging policies or
allocations of the council
the next procedural step for Council is
for it to consider the valid
representations that were submitted
during the consultation and determine
how it relates to them and determine any
actions arising from them before it
starts to support planning policies
the working group is only part way
through this activity and the reports of
strategy and resources committee has not
yet been scheduled for committee and
Council to formally consider those valid
representations
the policies must be prepared in
accordance with national policy and
legislation meaning they need to be
evidence-led informed continually
throughout their preparation by a series
of legal assessments namely
sustainability appraisal strategic
environmental assessment habitat
regulation for setting and equality's
impact assessment as well as
consultation with the public and
statutory facilities in accordance with
the council's approved consultation
policy the statement community
I can confirm that the sculpting of the
legal assessments I've mentioned for the
ldp review have yet to commence which
therefore appeals the writing of any
emerging policies or allocations
in preparing the ldp review the council
as the local planning Authority for the
modern District should be following due
process which is firstly lawful and
secondary procedurally sound as it is
these principles by which a planning
inspector will examine the ldp review in
the future and in doing so the council
also managed to reduce the risks that
its decisions could otherwise present
throughout the summer of new
there are currently no emerging policies
or proposed site allocations considering
emerging policies land allocations or
potential areas of development
restraints before due process has been
followed and before statutory
assessments have been prepared to inform
the council's choices but not in my
professional opinion be in accordance
with the law National policy or national
guidance
thank you
um thank you Mr Winslow that I believe
is the planning
point
now Miss Holmes will give some legal
thoughts
Miss Holmes thank you Chuck
okay uh the points that uh Mr Winslow
has raised
um we've also looked at from a legal
perspective he's obviously talking in
his professional capacity as a planning
officer the resolution requires
consideration of emerging policies
cannot be valid if there are no emerging
policies the motion presupposes such
policy exists and we know that they do
not When developing the plan there are
two types of policies strategic policies
set out the general principles and are
not site-specific the second type of
policy is a local policy local policy
should feed off that the Strategic
polity
excuse me strategic policies in that
they will inform the local policies site
allocations would be within the
definition of a local policy in the
motion there is reference to not only
the consideration of emergency emerging
policies but also policies relating to
author these would be local policies as
the planning advice is that the council
is some way off from producing any
emerging strategic policies policies it
must therefore be even further away from
producing any emerging local policies
and that of course applies to all for
all Thorn the motion is drafted gives
the impression the council wishes to
jump ahead of an orderly process that is
evidence-based and to consider local
policies in relation to Hawthorne when
the council is nowhere ready to do so I
have no doubt that such a decision at
this early stage could be judicially
reviewed successfully even if a
developer Waits until the plan is
adopted when it is not favorable to him
then this particular decision could be
cited showing that the plan has not been
produced based on evidence and therefore
is not lawful
following on from that point if the
council were to resolve to give special
treatment to all Thorn at this early
stage in the collection of information
this will be seen as making a special
case for all Thorn where no such
information is yet available for that to
be the case for example there have been
no statutory appraisals without the
sustainability appraisals there could be
no consideration of treating Hawthorne
differently from any other part of the
district I'm convinced that any
developer could successfully argue when
the plan is examined that it was not
produced in a systematic evidence-based
way furthermore any developer would be
able to judicially review the plan
simply because all Thorne has been given
special treatment when there was no
evidence to do so based on all the legal
assessments required in conclusion I'm
convinced that any developer would have
a strong case to argue against the
soundness of the plan in any examination
and would also be able to successfully
judicially review the plan because the
council has acted prematurely
thank you that's the legal position uh
Mr Dodson
um before I open the debate
thank you chairman
um I wanted to take the opportunity to
summarize what's been unusually strong
advice from both Mr Winslow and Mrs
Holmes in their respective expert
planning and legal views
I take from their submissions that the
council is following the appropriate
guidance in the development of the
council's local plan and that if
approved the motion on the table would
not only put the council outside of
guidance and process it would leave us
in a precarious legal position in
defending the council against judicial
review
and leave the authority and our
residents at much greater risk of
inappropriate development
the council has approved a governance
process around the development of the
local plan and established a working
group that reports through strategy and
resources committee to council whilst
all members are able to attend this
group I'm more than happy to work with
colleagues to arrange further all member
seminars in which members can engage to
fully understand the process and the
appropriate way forward thank you
chairman thank you Mr Dudley Mr uh
councilor Thompson
and by the way anything that's not
Cruella is absolutely fine
um I have to say I think this the motion
is premature as I can't say anything
against or in addition to the all our
professional officers I'm just trying to
put this in memberspeak that I get so
hopefully most of us will
um
you know we're not anywhere near
allocating we haven't gotten any
emerging policies I think there's a
concern I have a concern that there's a
conflation of assessment of
sites with allocations of sites I mean
yes there's been an initial assessment
yes last time around Ward members
certainly had some input into it now
back in the days of steam we were
actually each printed um
papers of the sites that have been put
forward in our Awards and we made our
comments back to the planning policy
offices well now we're no longer quite
in the age of steam we can all of us get
all of that off the public website which
is available to absolutely anybody
anywhere in the country or indeed the
world who wants to see it you know and
we can absolutely feel free to make
submissions to the planning policy
officers who are possible they've missed
something I don't know we do have local
knowledge that's part of why we're here
um but we can't consult on options until
we know that we we can't discuss options
until we know the results of the
consultation that went out and or you
know residents and others gave their
views on which which options they wanted
to see go forward and when we know more
about that we can look at it and I think
I believe that is a job for member
seminars which is what happened last
time around so thank you very much Jim
anybody else
uh councilor settled councilor Swain
uh thank you chairman the the this is a
complex process and that's that's a
crucial element
uh and there is concern from residents
about the sites that have come forward
and and that's understandable there is
that concern
however
until we establish our options which is
what we're starting to do next week
no sites are going to be selected and
once we've decided on our options the
options that we decide on then take take
10 months
to work through consultation before we
even go and look at which sites yeah and
it means when we get to we narrow it
down to three options a lot of those
sites will immediately disappear because
they won't fit within those options so I
understand yeah I've got concern about
the things that have come forward
however as officers are pointed out we
need to follow this due process so
therefore we are not legally challenged
at any time in the future on a Monday we
are starting to look at those options if
we want to slow this down we can and
that's the crucial thing this is our
local plan so if we think we're going
too fast we can slow it down we can take
more time with it we can yeah and it's
not as fast as it's going to be it's
going to be 2025 before this is finished
so it's not gonna be 2023 it's going to
be 20 25 before it's finished and that's
the crucial thing to remember if we make
it want to make it longer than that we
can do we're the ones that are in charge
of this and that's important to remember
and and we don't I don't think we need
this motion
because it's already in place in terms
of the process
thank you Council Council of swine
yes thank you chairman um
we leave to here uh
um Mr Mrs Holmes comment on the
inclusion of althorne it seemed to me
rather dangerous to include something
specific in this
in such emotion and could lead to things
like predetermination and so on
um councilor siddlers just said that
we're moving towards
um looking at overall options I think we
we haven't got the information to be
able to do that
for one thing
um I don't think you can make this
rather academic distinction between
setting strategic policies and then
local policies there's bound to be a
sort of feedback effect
um otherwise it looks too top down and
imposed you have to take account of the
of the realities on the ground
um so far well we have been dependent of
what sites have been put forward
um and I think the part of the problem
is the way this has all been presented
in planners speak and this was true of
the options document going out it was
written by planners for planners and
it's not surprising that the public
um sort of were phased by that and we've
now got this question of sites that are
acceptable or not or suitable or not
suitable acceptable or not so this may
be understood in planning circles but it
clearly
um is not understood publicly and I
think the terminology
um is unfortunate
having said that I think what we don't
have and what we need before we can move
forward is detailed um
analysis
of why
each site has been
put into a particular category having
simply a flea color scheme for banding
them is not enough a lot of criteria
were put forward in assessing locations
for people to comment on
um and I don't think we can really
assess this assess the sites without
knowing just why a particular site was
considered suitable and site B was not
until we have that information I don't
think members can contribute usefully to
moving the whole process forward thank
you Council councilor passenger
thank you Mr chairman um I'm back as as
I've declared I actually live in
Hawthorne and I'm the ward member and I
am speaking really on behalf of uh of of
my of my members and these are not my
views these are views that have been
sent to me either by email or people
contacting me personally
um when we talk about author
specifically which I agree why why
Hawthorne well I think author
is specific because of the way that this
this is so poignantly wrong for people
in the area what's happened is there is
there's a large site this is for
everyone's information and they have
decided that it's suitable for 1700
houses in the Healer they've done the
call for sites and there were three
sites and in between those sites there
is a road and one side is a site called
which I can't quite remember it may be l
l a t or something like that too and the
other side is lta4 or something like
that or three one side of the road was
considered unsuitable for development
and the other side of the road was
considered suitable for development
because
apparently you couldn't see the houses
because there's a few houses in the way
so that's the evidence base so for the
residents they look at this they look at
all Thorn that's got 600 houses no
school no post office nothing there's
absolutely nothing a pub and that has
been considered suitable and in the
Healer it says suitable for development
so consequently if you were a developer
you would be armed with a corporate site
that says this is suitable for
development now in planning speak which
I don't understand any of I must admit
and probably nor does anybody else
really
residents certainly don't
this is a catastrophe because they are
looking at school places they're looking
hospitals and they're thinking to
themselves why would we be considered
suitable now as you say why specifically
author will I agree probably across the
district there are many areas where
people feel the same but author
specifically is a very long way away
from any amenities you can't walk
anywhere the best thing it has is a
station which has a train that goes down
to Wickford and I believe that is the
main purpose why it's been considered
suitable so
for the residents you have to understand
this is a very very frightening time for
them they see their Village of 600
houses being increased by 200 I don't
know I mean you know how many houses
they want to put there
it's it's it's a worrying time and so
when you when you look at these call for
sites people don't understand especially
when they see the developers already
thinking or there's Chinese Whispers I'm
not quite sure what happened but there
is pre-apps going in there are
um surveyors going everywhere roads are
being adopted for them they they it
doesn't you know they can't think of oh
well you know we'll just leave it to the
council they see you as a threat they
see us as a threat
and that's the problem and if you go to
Hawthorne and I've never ever seen this
anywhere else there's Effigies hanging
off the lampposts there are signs up and
down the roads all over the area not
just one road it's across Hawthorne and
and in other parts of the area saying
NDC you know do your job NDC make the
right decision that's us that's me
you know and they come to me and it's
like you know explain this how is it
possible a village with nothing is being
considered suitable and you say this is
based on evidence
what evidence and I you know I I know
this is you know probably not planning
speak but at the end of the day we are
all going to be judged on this so we
need collectively to make sure that we
make the right decisions about school
places about hospitals about doctors
because that's what worries people
and how they get in and out of this area
we've got one road so across the
district we've got one road if that gets
blocked nobody gets out nobody goes to
work there's no work here everyone has
to travel so consequently why is author
specific because it typifies this sort
of this sort of judgment that people are
making sorry I think I think I have and
I'll leave it right there we'll leave it
there but I must admit I miss I must say
that I concur with everything that
Council Fluker has said and I will be
supporting his motion thank you thank
you for your passion uh councilor
Stevens
you're down on my list that's quite a
hard act to follow
um
you cancel the best Inger is
no he's passionate about old Thorne and
I'm actually quite surprised that I'm
not standing here having to be
passionate about tollsbury in quite the
same way because we've got a lot of land
that's allocated or sorry I shouldn't
say that that's
um part subject to the call for sites
that might be suitable but I have
understood very strongly from the
working party the meetings that I've
gone to that that's very much sort of
the first draft and that sites will go
away from that other sites will come
along and I've definitely understood
that and I haven't been to all of the
meetings because I wasn't on the group
until it was widened out to other
members so I think that that message has
come through quite loud and clear and
the other thing that I've been involved
with was quite early doors we held a
public meeting in Salisbury to say to
people you're going to see maps you're
going to see red areas of land around
tolsbury don't panic and people aren't
panicking so I would recommend to other
members if you've got frightened
residents and I get why people are
really really do get why people would be
frightened but I would say hold a public
meeting let people come let them come
and be passionate as you have just been
but you can just draw the heat out of it
a little bit and calm it down it doesn't
need to end up as an adversarial thing
against the officers who really are
trying to get our ldp through and we
don't want to be slowing that down thank
you a council stamp
on the lotion
I could give it to me because I think
it's quite straightforward we're dancing
more into this older than members are
seeing maybe more into this I think what
he's trying to ascertain is that members
are included yes this group was open so
I'm looking I was actually involved in
this last time in this planning policy
group this time so I have been included
in it
um whereas I think many of the members
haven't and they haven't had the
opportunity of chance to agree disagree
ask questions some of those are the
vociferous and vocal which is hardly
surprised many of you on one of those in
that category about it and but I think I
think it's really important that this
lotion is considered and I think it
should go to cancer and I think members
should be included more if they choose
not to chairman at the moment I've
attended working groups and I'd be quite
honest the full show of some members
attending working groups is disgraceful
was what I want to do this week
previously not all members are attending
so I think this motion is canceled
through from Hanson
attention that all members can attend
whether whether we like it or not this
is going to affect everybody and I think
the motion should be supported and as
long as it may I think all goals should
be taken out so there doesn't be any
specific Village or town or Hamlet
should be included with the advice what
to monetary officer is actually given
but I think I can make meters should be
held under the old members should be
kept up to date it's all right saying
you can access it not everybody has the
chance to access it at the time change
so I'm afraid I do support this uh just
recommendations um I'm going to come to
councilor Durham and then uh councilor
Lagann
um to to you and and then Council
approaches and sum up oh no sorry uh
councilor Chana the leader and then
Council of Luke yeah thank you thank you
chairman chairman it's absolutely
essential
that local members have an input into
any areas identified in in their
particular in their particular Wards
that's exactly as councilor Thompson
said that's exactly what happened last
time
um albeit we we were we all sat around
in the training room or whatever it's
called this week
um to you know look at the maps and
discuss the pros and cons of those areas
but I do take on board
what the monitoring officer has said
what the planning officer has said in
that this motion is premature and indeed
could land us in a load of legal legal
trouble
um and I commend councilor Bassinger um
on his really impassioned plea on behalf
of of author I've driven along the low
Burnham Road and I've seen all the signs
um the print has obviously done very
well out of that
um I just would point out that at the
very least I think he just perhaps has
expressed some a predisposition but
that's up to um Council Bassinger to
decide
um but chairman members absolutely must
be must be involved but I honestly don't
think that this uh this motion is um
either timely or advisable at this stage
Chancellor dragon
um
yeah councilor Derek uh I did I did say
I wanted to draw this because time's
getting on
the 31 and a half years
in quite such a problem as this has done
31 and a half years ago
and nothing really ever got out into the
public domain until science were being
looked at in this chamber we're
beginning to move on into the review of
that I was not like we call it as much
as saying and now in the last of this
District
again we didn't get this common I've got
told the other dog was 200 new houses
going inside oh that I don't know I
don't have the cameras for fluke I know
this is the first one I've heard of it
but it's bad people have been told
become some people in the council have
told them so where is all this
information coming from awful up until
four or five weeks ago
I've just been coming the whole thing
and then all of a sudden I got told by
this landowner was said well he's being
told that his site's perfect for him
so there's something happening people
are being told things and to be honest
that is the worry that it's too much
information
that is untried and untested getting out
of that
why is it getting out there and how is
he getting out there I don't know but I
keep hearing about it it's all different
places around the countryside that are
all about to be developed with multiple
Council has said it so somebody
somewhere is saying far too much or
saying it incorrectly
to give landowners
maybe and develop
you that their site's okay they're going
to get a job and that should never be
happening I don't know why it is
happening for that reason I was
supporting myself
um councilor Lagoon
having your writers second there too
I think my obviously support the motion
because it would have seconded
but listening to the degrees there's a
couple of points I'd like to
speak first of all as the passenger I've
commend you for that building package
exactly what we should do and let's end
up the speaker and talk about you over
yeah
um
look you know I have to use as well but
you you look at the things with an open
mind I know that
and he told Robert itself
we've got good officers working like
this I think it's it's your issue
the amount of information that's coming
out of course so being able to
contribute to the decision so I think
what we've got cassador everything's a
threat we can always have legal action
of course we have everything we do we
take the legal action I've asked you to
give me some information on previous
cases I'm still waiting for that and
that's I'm not having a car I've got a
piece it's always at the end of it but
as as an unfortunate Council I said have
this Castle had the testicular fortitude
okay and that that's that that resonated
in my mind it's an unfortunate phrase
and I apologize because I I would prefer
myself to get a good kid
um but you know if it was a legal
emotion why was it all inside
now you can tell about the United chair
that this is an absolute Vice
so I don't think we should show away
from impressively but actually because
you can always find manipulation and all
I hear is you take a decision review we
basically have the map to happen
anything to happen
so we need to be strong enough because
it's such a powerful powerful part of
the shaping of the council that counts
facility
now what we do now is for tomorrow so if
you haven't got schools we haven't got
infrastructure we haven't got anything
and we're going to cost you right
councilor Tanner
uh thank you chairman well I'm just
going to go back to what I said at the
beginning this wasn't about planning
application and it's not about an
allocation in Hawthorne I do think we
need to be mindful of that and I said at
the beginning this was about process and
procedure and it's to do with timing
actually I feel chairman and it's
regarding
um you know policies and allocations
it's not where or whatever it's when and
the timing is Yet to Come and in fact
councilor siddle I will say I think he
made the point very clearly there is a
meeting coming up on the 26th there's a
whole book
um done in there I appreciate totally
Council of Bassinger as the world member
um you know making the statements he may
have done which he explained were not
his views the views he has received and
of course that's what he feels he needs
to do as a world member but I would urge
members to Bear caution in light of what
we've heard from the three officers
tonight from the planning's perspective
legal and what Mr Dodson has to say
chairman that's all I'm going to say at
this juncture Council fluka thank you
chairman I mean that's that's a huge
amount
down this debate and I think that
actually gives way to having an
extraordinary music so we can fully
understand the points in the deputy
commission officers mentioned in this
doing so but if we can just mention this
or go back and visit this thing about
policy I mean on the council website
there's a three color scheme
applied to all of these sites so where
does that policy come from there has to
be a policy there that's done this and
when we talk about these sites that
applicants have been told they're
suitable them I actually know of one
place where an applicant is told that
their side was not suitable
suitable and they came back to the
policy team and then they were told it
was so what is this policy you know it's
not emerging emergency
so what is that policy that they're
using it all seems very strange to me
because these are all Green Field sites
all Greenfield sites
that's just really let's just drill in
Supremacy again because there are many
but before I do that so let's think
about judicial reviews because every
literally I don't think a day goes past
without members being sweating with a
judicial review I don't like it do some
research find out how many judicial
reviews have taken place
very I mean you would think there's like
10 is every days against Council it's
not I think the last one in the film
star ones which are generally lost his
job but they never had the review in
here they just told them to resubmit the
application and as a fast judicial would
use it to say if we don't have an
extraordinating to look at these
policies that aren't emerging and I'll
come to those in a moment then yes we
could be criticized because Council has
not been given the opportunity to review
the policies that aren't emerging so we
haven't got any emerging policies
a Chancellor civil which just confirmed
something that I always knew and that is
on the 26th of this month I think that
microphone was working on Monday on the
26th of this month which is Monday
the working group are going to consider
policy options and make a decision
working groups don't make a decisions
how many members here are on that policy
working group
so for the benefit of the tape there's
about four people I think I might be
five people so right they are going to
make a decision on Council fluka you're
giving out incorrect information well
they well I've I've been told I am on
the policy chairman I am not because I
am I think Monday's meeting is open to
all members yes it is that you can't
vote because you're not on the working
group no there's no voting chairman they
are asked chairman they are asking the
working group is going to be asked to
consider policy options with the sole
intention of moving certain policies
forward those options they are not my
words that was what we were told at the
last planning policy working group that
is why three minutes I think in the Ben
for the benefit democracy chairman and
since I've stood up I've had about 10
emails about this saying that we're
actually being filibusted and this
should go ahead chairman Mr Dodson well
the chairman with the greatest respect I
think you'll find I'm the last person to
speak on this motion and it should be
put you but before I do councilor Fluker
you have been put in forward some
incorrect information and I think that
needs to be clarified and Mr Dodson will
either clarify it or or agree with you
awesome
thank you chairman the group will review
the options around the sides what they
won't be doing is making a decision they
may be making a recommendation that
would go through the governance process
that has been agreed by this Council
which is through strategy and resources
and Council that they won't be making a
decision they will be doing exactly what
the counselor asked them to do and
engage in members in the options around
those various
um that will then determine the sites
not at this thank you thank you right um
I wish to make an amendment to my motion
uh I've
yes
so chairman I wish to remember my motion
and uh and I wish is your second to
agree yes they will do
yeah they will because
no no I'm not speaking to you but I'm in
communication at the moment with
councilor Helm and he thinks it's a
great idea Council again I know he's on
phone he's coming on on my phone so some
um so chairman I would just ask to
remove the words including those in
Hawthorne and including those in
Hawthorne Ward chairman so we just
delete those few words at the end this
gives this gives Council chairman this
motion the opportunity for all of us to
debate this I think we should be given
that opportunity yes
do members agree that Amendment yes
right thank you so the the um
substantive motion uh now stops at um
the local development plan
is that is that your Amendment counselor
Luca it is indeed thank you right
um uh Mr Dodson can you read out the
motion as it's now amended
okay
that the council calls an extraordinary
meeting to take place in not less than
10 working days to consider the emerging
policies of the review of the
2014-2029 local development plan
um uh right members um that that's the
motion you'll be voting on uh I'd like
to make a comment
um I don't believe I I will be able to
convene an extraordinary council meeting
within 10 working days so please give me
some uh movement on on on that we'll
leave the motion as it stands but
understand I don't think I can convene a
meeting within 10 working days I know
what you're going to say the council
says it will it will but I can't do it
30.
I like to put it
it says the council calls an
extraordinary meeting to take place in
not less than 10 working days in other
words it's more than 10 more than 10
days looking 14 could be 21. okay thank
you thank you I'm uh thank you for that
correction I misread it
um that's very welcome news right I now
put the motion to the vote those all all
those in favor
oh
um
[Music]
those those things in favor say agree
those against say against uh Mr Dodson
caller art role please
for passenger agree
counselor Miss Beale
councilor Bell
councilor Boyce against
councilor chap Mrs China
against
councilor dueck
councilor Durham against
councilor Edwards against
councilor Mrs Fleming against
councilor fluka
councilor heard agree
councilor hubner
against
councilor Hull
councilor keys against
councilor Lagan
councilor Morgan
against
councilor Morley
councilor Nunn against
councilor Shaughnessy
councilor siddle against
councilor spencerley
councilor stamp
councilor Stevens against
councilor Mrs stilts
against
councilor Swain against
and councilor Mrs Thompson against thank
you
we have 10 4 and 16 again
um that motion is lost uh 10 4 and 16
against thank you members uh within five
minutes of my cut off time so we're
gonna have to move on a bit uh we now
move on to a gender item
um
11 questions in order procedure rules
six three which notice has been given I
have no such questions
agenda item 12 updating the
Constitutional report of the corporate
governance working group
um uh yes do you agree those
recommendations
I heard and agree is that everybody
agreed it will help help thank you very
much thank you
um a gender item three uh 13 uh
performance governance and audit
committee and the corporate governance
working group page 37 to
38
reports of the monitoring officer leader
would you like to give that
I'm quite happy for uh
do you want me to help Mrs Holmes to do
it German she stood up yeah okay
um Miss Holmes please
apologies chair leader uh this report uh
I'd be very brief hopefully you've read
it uh relates into a decision as to
which or how the council would like
matters in relation to the view of the
Constitution to be dealt with uh the
options at the moment there is currently
in the remit of both the corporate
governance working group
um and the performance governance and
audit Committee in their terms of
reference the purposes of the report is
for Council to decide which of those two
bodies should deal with matters in
relations the Constitution whether that
be the corporate governance working
group ceases to exist and it the matters
are then dealt with by PG a or whether
you wish for the corporate governance
working group to carry on with those
matters making recommendations in the
usual way and for the terms of reference
of PG a to be amended accordingly thank
you thank you chair uh Leela do you wish
to say anything
um which one do you want to recommend if
any well chairman my view is and with
all due respect to the performance
governance and audit committee my
preference is actually to keep the
corporate governance working group
because that allows informal discussion
in much greater depth than perhaps the
committee can and also it doesn't just
cover all those issues I recall the
corporate governance actually looking at
various other elements that to do with
the Constitution or other matters
regarding the council that had been
decreed to it and so I think it's a
valuable body that would actually be
lost if we don't have that working group
in position and I think I'm correcting
that councilor siddle actually was the
chairman at one point and I do recall
um quite a number of interesting subject
matters that arose in that working group
which was chaired very very well and it
allowed actually members to thresh out
um and give their views
um it's a bit when you're in the chamber
I'm not saying we don't give our views
but you can do it in a way so much
differently within the working group
environment and between officers which
allows I would call a greater degree of
exchange because you're you are
concentrating on those items so it's
nothing against PGA but I do think the
corporate governance has been in
existence for quite a while and I think
to lose it
um would be an error on behalf of this
Council and how we operate in governance
and everything thank you chairman so
that's your recommendation my
recommendation is to keep the corporate
governance working
uh councilor stamp
Ed and I think if decisions and
decisions are being taken maybe not
decisions and that you feel you can't
discuss them openly in an open committee
that's how we follow a counselor fluid
for Sinatra which is actually
transparency I certainly don't feel as
though I can't say anything when I'm
sharing PG a and I would hope that
anybody else who sits on pgna feels that
they can say whatever they want So
within reason as long as it's not
offensive positive journey and I think
the uh the working group should cease
and I think the responsibility should go
to pdna and I think that's where that
committee is designed to do and like I
said chairman look at yourself writing
properly and hopefully it is and it will
discuss hopefully transplant if they
want to disagree and I would like to go
against that recommendation
when it fails if it fails Sherman
um uh I I actually chaired um uh this
particular
um uh corporate governance working group
and the arguments at that time uh were
simply
um that wasn't a matter of one being in
public and one being in in private but
the PG a
um uh has members would have it would
have Members Only from the bgna whereas
the corporate governance working group
is a working group of the council and it
can draw membership from across the
council and it would if that existed I
as chairman who I believe actually a
chairman should be a member of this
work working group
um that's that that I'm just putting the
The View that I put now councilor
Fleming actually disagreed with me and
took your uh your view uh councilor soon
uh thank you chairman and thank you for
your very common words leader uh in in
terms of the situation is is quite an
interesting uh dilemma of this
particular scenario and I remember
having conversations with uh councilor
Jarvis when he was a member at the
council about this particular thing one
of the things that I feel about PG a
is it needs more
and it needs more
big teeth bite whatever you want to call
it more depth that they can go into so I
agree that this should really go under
the committee itself yeah it's called
governance it's in the title so
therefore it should be in that committee
and not as a separate working group
because that is where the government's
governance is decided that's where the
governance decisions are making I can
see the reasoning that yes it will it
will come over all committees however
it's about setting the Constitution PG a
is about setting the Constitution so
therefore it should be within that
committee yeah thank you um what I'll do
uh now to to move things on I'll take
the vote on uh Mrs Chandler's and if
that if if that the fours and against
uh uh we'll we'll give us the answer
councilor Sam you happy with that
it's in the report
it's in the report chairman yeah I I I
do I do I am conscious of the time and
um it's nearly time to shut this meeting
down
um those in favor of the leaders
proposal please show
nine those against
then pay the corporate governance
working group will cease to exist as of
this minute uh thank you members uh a
gender item 14 uh member training
criteria leader
yes this is really uh chairman to
establish criteria to fairly manage
um member training approaches that have
been happening what's been happening
chairman um unfortunately at one time
you may recall we did have leader
support and member support and through
their transformation and that no is
longer in existence and so obviously I'm
dealing with all those matters but
otherwise at some time the triaged or
helped redone the administration of so
regarding training what's been happening
is I actually have been involved in
training giving to some members and then
recognize that whether they're free or
not perhaps we need something to channel
it through and to make sure because
there is a budget and we ought to have
something that can be Channel through
and actually applied with some criteria
or a method in which we could be aware
of what's being spent in the budget
certainly
um apart from Austin recently didn't
have all the costs that have been made
and some members have gone into tens of
disease training as well
um not going through that mode so this
would actually put things in order and
you can see the officer has prepared how
a matter of decide on training quickly
decided and there is also then what I
call the safety belt there will be
members become involved at a certain
time which is described within the
report
and then it's done on a scoring and
members certainly come into play a group
and that would include the committee
chairman
um the leader I can't remember if it
actually lead but what's ever described
in a report so is that safety valve if
the scoring goes into an area where it
could be a bit mixed whether that
training should be carried out or not
and I think it would be sensible to have
this gem because it then takes the
pressure for me trying to keep a list of
who might be doing what or who comes to
me and asks what and it will also keep
it fair because also then I can't be
accused of perhaps giving preferential
treatment to a member who might come
regularly for training or anything and
then the budget is all kept within the
governance of the appropriate officer
which is Cheryl Hughes who is obviously
known
intrinsically linked to the governance
of this Authority so it's really to
assist the training matters for members
and keep a clear record chairman of the
budget and um you know who's attending
what and the criteria and everything are
defined in the report thank members
agreed the recommendations
right councilor stamp
um I'd like to actually say I think this
has been come to council because of an
incident that happened with me and I do
apologize when I feel as though it is
um I wanted to sit I wanted to take a
particular training course as the
chairman of PG a and I was told that I
couldn't do it because it was more
suitable for a different committee and
not my committee and if you actually
look at the terms of reference from my
committee chairman it was suitable for
my committee and our committee signs off
the account and the business assessment
and everything to do with that now I I
was really quite upset that I was told I
couldn't do training I take my role very
seriously and I will not recommend to my
committee that you know if I don't know
what I'm talking about you may disagree
with me on many things but I think many
of you'll agree that I try to do things
properly so forgive me um if the
opposite of things if it hasn't been
because of my um
difficult situation I was told I can
attend the training what I would like to
point out is this training worship is
less than Berlin Town Council so not
annual based basis Vernon is a Small
Town Council and we allow more training
in our budget than what this Council
does is for members who are making
important decisions over the district
terms
no no I'm just going to ask what you're
going to recommend uh it should happen
mending that it still stays with the
leader she should make that final
decision and I don't think it should go
to offices to make decisions on member
training they can they can suggest and
make sure some of it and I think we've
got the traits and trainers here cancer
Signal's an excellent trainer and I
think we discussed a while ago what
mental Traders should be given and I
think that needs to be addressed and if
members want to look at the statutory
training on what side of the degree it's
here and our members have actually the
researched and seen what statutes
training we have and what training we
get so now I don't agree it goes to the
officer I think it should stay with the
leader okay councilor Darren
yeah thank you thank you very much
chairman chairman I don't nobody is
going to say that valid training isn't
absolutely essential for member
development and so that members can do
their jobs uh adequately and to be kept
up to date with various changes Etc we
have to be mindful that there are lots
of different types of training out there
and there is uh training that is
undertaken by the LGA the CCA the C the
dcn sit for Etc
uh which are valid
there are members will will get frequent
emails offering training they come up
with a a an attractive
um headline saying you know do you want
to learn more about this or that and
there is a fee attached to that in
nearly every case they are sponsored
privately organized training sessions or
they call themselves training sessions
but they are usually funded by pressure
groups interest groups or even
commercial entities and and that you
know despite the fact that you may get
an email that looks innocuous
um it isn't in fact what I would call a
terribly valid training course we should
have a member development strategy
and that member development strategy
should identify bona fide day courses
for various positions leadership Finance
whatever and should uh should be uh
these courses should be open
subject to budget and bear in mind that
the LGA do fund some courses uh for us
I've been lucky enough to attend several
that have been completely funded
um but you know we we really must have a
list of the courses that are suitable
and be prepared if necessary to fund
those how that is worked out
um
it it doesn't really matter but provided
that the courses that the members are
put forward for are legitimate and
operated by independent bodies uh
Council
um again please members time is moving
on
it
I don't think anyone knows what training
I need to you know to be able to operate
in my position better than I do
and I don't think it's right that that
decision is made by obviousness
I've had a great with all due respect
I've not had any training since I've
been here I've seen a lot of
presentations
but I've not had any training now again
cancer signal cancer spends to be able
to talk to you till probably the end of
the week about knowing Styles and how
different people learn in different ways
and we need to take that into account as
well one size does not fit at all thank
you
uh thank you chairman uh we do have a
member training working group which uh
hasn't met for for quite a long time and
it was set up to Define this sort of
thing so I think rather than agreeing
this recommendation we call a meeting of
the working group to Define this and
look at what is the best way yeah and
especially with the election coming in
obviously we need a really good
induction program for next year's intake
because there wasn't one when I joined
um yeah members uh
uh shall we withdraw this paper and and
and and look at a proposal I'll do
another proposal chairman if you like
yeah go and then later
I might as well everyone else is having
a go actually that's not a bad point I
mean I want to make it clear to council
some it wasn't the issue to do with
yours I mean I get inundated with
training courses and some of them are
highly expensive you think oh this
sounds good and then you see something
for a virtual meeting of 345 quid or
something so I don't quite ascertain how
that can be we're not talking about
anything free I try to make sure
everyone gets the freebies there was one
I thought would be interest a lot of
members so I made inquiries as to what
it would mean if every member had the
opportunity and I blew the budget and
that's when the reality came and it is
quite hard when you're doing this to do
the administration myself so that
certainly would be something that needs
to be looked at but I'm more than happy
actually to go with that suggestion let
this go to the member training um
working group they can look at this
report and actually what it was done it
wasn't a case it was quite Fair scoring
applied to those elements you can see
and then as I said there was the member
panel that would come in chairman of PGA
SNL councilor white Council said it will
be there myself exactly if we're going
to withdraw it I'll let go
that's very quickly
um
you know we do need to save money as a
council we all know that and there's a
lot on here about in-house training and
I just think the offices I've seen
already as a new member officers trying
really hard to deliver training but my
question would be is I'm not part of
that working group
um it's maybe they look at providing
training for this for the officers to
provide training because
yeah you you do need that because from
what I've seen so far and I've seen
officers really trying but they need to
have those skills because we're making I
I think I think I think you're making is
confirming the point
um
that we need to withdraw this and and uh
and I know Mr lesbian wishes to speak
but I haven't got time for him to speak
so do members agree that this be
withdrawn yeah
15 a12 to uh 120.
um
I propose the recommendations chairman
as per the report okay agreed councilor
Lagan
okay
strategic theme for 5.1 the base
strategy Associated corporate outcome
supports reducing the impact of
pollution on the environment that they
reduce
yeah thank you members agree the
recommendations
right and then we go to a gender item
16. questions to the leader now in view
of the time I'm I'm going to miss that
tonight I'm sorry
now uh councilor fluka I did I did wish
to get the meeting done by half past 10
about half past nine
now
yes yes please please do
um
uh I now uh
uh leader go on carry on
um
thank you thank you
um business by reason of special
circumstances considered by the chairman
to be urgent agenda item 17 under PNC
there is another item uh which will be a
statement from Mr Dodson
um so can I then
uh have the proposal to resolve that
under section 100 a for the Local
Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for the
following items of business on the
grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three
of part one of schedule 12a to the ACT
and this satisfies the public interest
in relation to management of resources
uh commercial options for Prince's Road
and a statement from Mr Dodson is that
seconded okay is that great
thank you can the link be
the link be turned off